انه هذا اخر كتاب طلع اللي هو مجموعه
مقالات
طلع عن دار جديد
حلو
[موسيقى]
في لبنان
وهيدا مقالات كمان مقالات اطول شوي من
مقالات حدثت مره
[موسيقى]
هيدا
المشرق العربي طالعه رياض الريش اكبر كتاب
ضخم طالع ممكن استخدامه حجر الضرب
ايه انه
رايي في كثير جامع شي جامع بين الافكار
السياسيه السائده
بمنطقتنا هو الرومنطي
روماتيكيه بمعنى توليد الفكره من فكره مش
من احتكاك
يعني
اذا استعملنا لغه فرويد
مبدا اللذي بيغلب على مبدا الواقع فشي
بتقدر تقشر له باللغه السياسيه المتداوله
بالسلوك السياسي بالتجارب نفسها
[موسيقى]
بالاهداف اللي بتنحط اللي
مقطوعه الصله تقريبا بالقدرات القائمه
الفعليه
بتغليب الحركه نفسها على الانجاز يعني انه
فينا نقول الحلم بشيء يستحيل تحقيقه الحلم
بالشيء الذي يستحيل تحقيقه وعدم الاهتمام
بالتحقيق
يعني مثلا
زعيم سياسي بيفشل ما بهمنا انه فشل ضل
بنضل نحبه ونسمنه تثمين رفيع وعالي والى
اخره الانجاز ما يقعد
النيه بتصير
كان يرغب ان كان يرغب كان عنده فيما لو
كان هون كان يرغب كان عنده كل اللواير
حسنه والاستعدادات والبطوله والكذا والى
اخره بس ما مشي الحال
هاي يعني
[موسيقى]
في محطات اساسيه بالتاريخ الحديث تبعنا
فيها شيء بيتكلم